there were homes here once
children playing
and a community
now everything is submerged in a
never-ending vista of water
the people of umri now perched carefully
on a muddy mound they've been forced to
call home
the children dragging branches to create
shelters
swimming and washing in water mixed with
sewage
there are 300 people here they're
stranded on all these banks the health
center submerged the government hasn't
brought them a thing
a third of pakistan is now under water
in a country this big that's difficult
to comprehend
an estimated 33 million people affected
and the country is struggling to keep up
with need for aid with the navy and army
drafted into help i am seeing every day
it is a very
severe situation
and
this
catastrophic situation has
led to a very very grim
economic situation
as we drove further into sindh province
a notorious desert-like landscape has
switched from golden hues to blue
trees and crops struggling to remain
pakistani officials are unequivocal they
believe this is a very real consequence
of climate change its citizens have been
experiencing extreme weather conditions
that have come together in an
extraordinary nexus starting with a heat
wave that saw temperatures right here in
sindh province reaching 53 degrees and
in the north of the country those
soaring temperatures caused the glaciers
to melt sending water gushing down into
pakistan's major rivers and then we are
now in the midst of a monster monsoon
this is not a river that has broken its
banks its rainfall settling on dry
ground
here on the outskirts of dadu
the families told us of their escape and
anger at the lack of support
i've got little children
we just managed to save them but why
isn't anybody helping us
the landowners and authorities here
don't care about us
pakistan is amongst some of the lowest
contributors to greenhouse gas emissions
but its small carbon footprint will not
save it from global climate change
its people will be
and are amongst the worst affected
for now they have escaped the water
and build skeletal shelters to escape
the heat of the sun
simon orsin sky news dadu pakistan
the united kingdom is home to the
largest pakistani community in europe
for many of the more than one million
british pakistanis the floods are having
a direct impact on their families sky's
becky cottrell's been to speak to a
freight courier company owner here about
how he's helping his family in pakistan